so um are you on the road or what do you
let's let's talk about now yeah okay do
you have a podcast yes what's it called
Spears and Steinberg and you do it by
yourself uh no my feature comedian Andy
Steinberg uh like I yes Jewish Berg
[__] uh
we do it on the road uh week to week
yeah uh it's it's been out for about
going on five years now it's all the
people this is my camera right yeah
right to all the people please subscribe
also go to our YouTube channel
spearsberg pod but we didn't get on
YouTube until probably two years in so
if you really want to follow the podcast
and I know 400 plus episodes is a lot
but I suggest you listen from the
beginning and go in order because of the
callbacks the jokes certain things
you'll understand uh binge baby yeah
binge Spears and Steinberg I mean we
crack cocaine man once you get a hit you
know you're in your dressing room
[__] on the floor
I think dude I honestly I think um my
fans are gonna go see it I hope they do
man I'm telling you so many people was
like yo you need to do tigerbelly yo yo
yeah so I was just I know they're gonna
like this because they I'm glad you came
and also I want to say something else
bold oh
I want you back on you should add me
back you know what I do once a year we
should do it yeah yeah because he's such
a great impressionist too and so right
maybe you can teach him how to do
Impressions and stuff this is where the
war will start again though why because
you just promised something oh no no
listen I I know no no no look at your
boss like Will Smith said in Suicide
Squad oh you thought I'm talking to you
I'm talking to your boss yeah no you're
gonna reach out to her yeah get on yes
and I'll See You Again
y'all were married no just dating
I mean we eat such a long it's just a
long thing give me Cliff Notes can you
can you give me listen just at the end
of the day we decided that uh we should
you know love each other be best friends
which we are I love ourselves still do
the Pod we do the Pod together I was at
our house a couple days ago I mean we
you know we see each other see that
that's part of my growth because I can't
one you break up
no I can't be around some [__] that
I've been in and we just laughing yeah
have you been in something a decade long
yes okay and still it was like I can't
know you I'm not live by Taliban rules
how much you mind [__] you mine oh I
see yeah yeah yeah yeah I don't have
Taliban people go Catholic
but we're still no he's a little Taliban
still because like he um the other day
he came over for dinner and I was like
Hey like what if I start getting serious
with somebody and he was like No And
also [__] you can't get married and I
was like well what if I wanna you know
kind of like I I wanted I was
considering doing motherhood alone like
getting like a sperm donor and he was
like no no don't do that you do that
oh you can do that oh you don't want
just a real dude you want to do whatever
you want I'm just I was kidding by the
way so wait a minute if she has you have
male friends yeah he's dated a lot more
than me I've dated like two guys since
our break would you are you not one of
them dudes would be like yo we could all
hang out you her and her man no no no
but I would have been I would have been
okay with him like bringing another girl
in but women but
like we do that's true I know two dudes
right right their names and what they
look like that she is you know what I
mean right that I've dated yeah yeah I I
don't say their names you don't have
that and their names aren't lit I have a
list oh and what was that list this is
my own list listen male real male
friendship don't get tested till you
help a [__] bury somebody
keep them names dog oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah them [__] at the beach
[Music]
are you married what's going on with you
anything
I'm really trying to reconcile with got
two kids with you know we working on it
you have two kids yeah I got three kids
and they live with you no baby mama baby
mom yeah yeah but you guys uh were
broken up and now you're trying to like
work it work out we've been broken up
back together